foreign
[Music]
we are live it is 11 A.M Eastern on
February 9th 2022 and hello to all of
you wise people who are tuning in to the
Reuben report direct message hosted by
Dave Rubin instead of watching the
lunatics on The View on ABC right now
you've made the right choice and I
promise not to let you down uh of course
we are live streaming on rumble on
YouTube and on Blaze TV if you could
subscribe tap notification bell all that
sort of stuff it would be appreciated uh
and you know we got incredible feedback
yesterday from the show we did something
that we had sort of never really done
here before which is do a sort of
narrative show that we didn't really
cover four or five stories as we
normally do but it was a through line
show for about 40 minutes sort of
tracing what has happened related to Joe
Rogan and the rumble situation and why
the media is going after him and the
inner authentic apologies and how cancel
culture makes people do all sorts of
weird things that they know deep down
ain't right but everybody's got their
own stuff that they're dealing with
um and I really felt when we ended the
show I was like I want to do more of
that that was good it felt dense and
real to me
um give a full shout out to Phoenix our
new associate producer who helped put
that together and we thought we could do
a little bit more of that kind of stuff
we're not going to do it all the time
but today we are going to do a similar
show in that you can see right now how
the media and the Democrats are really
shifting when it comes to the covid
narrative you can really feel it if
you're paying attention to what's online
suddenly like this shift to like oh we
do want to open schools and we do want
you out of masks and we don't want any
more lockdowns and we never were really
for all of those things and you can see
them doing it in real time and the
reason that they're doing it is because
the midterms are coming all the polling
is showing that the Republicans are
going to win the house in a landslide
maybe even the Senate that there could
be a whole bunch of other massive shifts
and the Democrats are realizing that
people don't like these horrific
authoritarian policies so we're going to
give you a through line for the next
half hour of sort of how we got here
where we were where we're going and
we're going to relate it to everything
happening right at this very moment so
sit back get your coffee or your tequila
or whatever you're drinking and let's do
this thing so where this all started
in the last couple days where the shift
really started was that Stacy Abrams who
is the woman who lost the Georgia
gubernatorial race a couple years ago
was speaking to a classroom of children
and this image leaked out here's Stacy
Abrams and oh my God look at her sitting
Indian style is such a big smile on her
face and as you can see she is not
masked but all the children are mass
that seems odd I mean she's no offense a
rather large woman and that is one of
the main coborn comorbidities when it
comes to covid but putting aside that
this image this really horrific I mean
this joking aside this is a really
horrific image look what they have done
to children and this shit-eating grin
that this woman has as she sits there
with all of these masked children who
are at no risk to each other who are at
no risk to the teachers etc etc and we
all know this and they keep doing it
okay now Stacy Abrams what's interesting
about her is nobody really knows
anything about this woman other than the
media loves her and as I said she lost
the gubernatorial race in Georgia which
by the way she uh didn't really concede
you may have remembered that yeah why
Stacy Abrams is still saying she won so
Democrats are allowed to contest
elections they're allowed to question
election Authority and they're allowed
to you know go oh maybe it wasn't legit
that's cool when Republicans do it
Insurrection evil arrest these people
they're scary but Stacy Abrams went on
CNN to explain why she took the mask off
and left the kids masked I took the mask
off because I was speaking remotely to
two other classrooms and wanted all of
them to hear me
oh she just wanted people to hear her so
it was cool if maybe she was going to
transmit the deadly virus that
everyone's freaking out over for the
last two years it's totally cool she
just wanted people to hear because
nobody
nobody could hear what you're saying but
you know so she just you know in the
interest of here having other classrooms
that were watching on Skype hear her she
could transmit her Evil deadly germs and
in that case it would be okay because
obviously she has a lot of seriously
important stuff to say
all right it continues uh here is the
infallible fauci a man who has gotten
almost all of this wrong from the
beginning who has contradicted himself
endlessly for two years who has sent
emails telling friends that they can go
on vacation and not wear masks while he
was telling us to double mask and a
whole bunch more he has been lambasted
and smacked around by one of our good
Senators uh Rand Paul you guys have all
seen those videos uh here he is
defending the forced masking of children
and what about the debate over masks in
Illinois schools Dr fauci says he
believes masks and vaccinations are
helping to keep schools open before we
start talking about pulling back on them
let's get that Dynamic of the virus in
the community low enough so that we can
feel safe in pulling back on the
requirement for children to wear masks
okay so this is just the endless dribble
that fauci has given us from day one
notice he never gives us the number we
have to get the dynamic low enough
something something but they never say
what that low number would be what the
dynamic exactly would be they never talk
about how
99.998 or something like that percentage
of children uh you know survived covid
and all of that stuff and that natural
immunity works I know you know all of
this stuff so it's just this endless
drivel from this man and then what
happens is that dribble then starts
affecting teachers and administrators
and this true lunatic this is Randy
Weingarten who is the teachers union
president uh this past weekend talking
about why kids should still be in masks
with Dr McBride just told us about Mass
not particularly being effective for
children what's the argument against
taking off masks in schools well the
argument is that you have well let me
just say this I am in favor of an off
ramp on mass right the real issue
becomes r is this is is the spread low
enough so that there's no dissemination
or transmission in schools and it's not
the teachers transmitting to kids
um it's more kids and kids particularly
in elementary schools right now and so
the question really becomes do we have
that's why I like what Massachusetts has
done because what they've said is that
on a school bus school basis they said
if there's 80 percent vaccination rates
then those schools can lift the mandates
okay I want to be nice and not
hyperbolic or anything here that woman
is a soulless wench she is a liar okay
she has forced all of these school
closures she is a progressive activist
activist masking as someone who is
supposed to be running this the the
teachers unions to keep schools open and
make sure our kids are educated but what
she really is is a progressive activist
that's all that she is she said
something there that is completely
insane she said the real issue is the
spread is low enough for no
dissemination
it is impossible
it is literally impossible that zero
people children adult whatever will
neither get covid nor transmit covid
in the old days when I was a kid
sometimes there'd be a sick kid at
school and he'd go to the nurse and then
he'd go home and maybe another kid got
sick or maybe a teacher got sick and
maybe they wouldn't come to school the
next day but there was no there was no
concept of zero covid that no one will
ever get anything that we will sit in
her medically sealed boxes and be
perfectly safe from everything that is
counter to what life is all about so you
can see that these people just lie about
everything these are the same people
let's not forget last week Eric Garcetti
the mayor of Los Angeles who said he
holds his breath when he takes pictures
of people lying [ __ ] artist Gavin
Newsom the the the psychopath running
the once great state of California who
said that he wore his mask except when
he was drinking water at the football
game except there's plenty of video that
he didn't and I don't have to go into
the hypocrisy about him him and I guess
I now have to throw in five dollars
because I mentioned California to let's
say we're up to 150 every time I throw
in five it becomes 25 but it's all right
um anyway what I said at the top of the
show is really what I want to focus on
right now because it's not just the
hypocrisy right they they're doing the
hypocrisy intentionally they want to
show you that they rule over you that's
why AOC goes to events in fifty thousand
dollar gowns while all of the staff is
wearing masks and she is not they want
to show you they are better than you
they control you and you better be
afraid of them I think you all
understand that now but I wanna what I
want to focus on today because this is
where it's now shifting is that the
narrative is actually moving in real
time we have seen it in the last 24 or
48 Hours where suddenly oh masks maybe
they're not great maybe uh we should
open up things maybe we've been really
the one saying this the whole time this
is CNN's lyanna Wen she is one of their
medical correspondents she's the former
president of Planned Parenthood that's
just an interesting tidbit of
information there and we've got a bit of
a compilation of her on how the science
has changed do you agree with the move
I do there was a and is a time and place
for pandemic restrictions but when they
were put in it was always with the
understanding that they would be removed
as soon as we can and in this case
circumstances have changed case counts
are declining also the science has
changed we know that vaccines protect
very well against Omicron which is the
dominant variant everyone five and older
have widespread access to vaccines and
we also know about one-way masking the
idea that even if other people around
you are not wearing masks if you wear a
high quality mask that also protects you
the wearer too and so in this case I'm
not saying I don't think anyone really
is saying that no one should ever wear
masks but rather that the responsibility
should shift from a government mandate
imposed from the state or the Local
District or the school rather it should
shift to an individual responsibility by
the family who can still decide that
that their child can wear a mask if
needed
man that is just extraordinary I'm not
for gulags for my political opponents
but I I don't know what you do with
someone like her I mean that is
profoundly evil she has been pushing
mandates she has been pushing masks the
idea that everyone has to wear them now
she's saying you can wear too and they
shouldn't have to do it also the science
has changed no the science hasn't
changed and this idea that suddenly oh
now we know that the the vaccines work
on Omicron two weeks ago they were
telling us it didn't work on Omicron and
that's why everybody was getting coveted
over over Christmas in the new and New
Years and everything else so now here's
the compilation of her saying completely
the opposite over the past two years one
other thing that we're seeing now and I
think this is a response to the rise of
Delta is more willingness among
governmental authorities and others to
mandate the vaccine we saw that
yesterday the VA said it's going to
require the vaccine for its employees we
saw the mayor of New York the governor
of California do you anticipate seeing
more in this vein more requirements
yes and it cannot come soon enough you
can remain unvaccinated if you so choose
but if you want to be in public and
potentially you could be infecting
others with a dangerous and sometimes
fatal disease that's highly
transmissible then there's an obligation
of society I mean I think you could have
an opt-out the way that France for
example or Italy and other countries are
doing saying that if you want to be in
bars restaurants movie theaters Etc
either be vaccinated or have proof of a
recent negative test I hope that we
moved in that direction as a country
here because at the end of the day I
don't really understand why people have
the choice to be infecting our
vulnerable children or immunocompromised
people or even others who have taken the
responsible choice to get vaccinated
sure and I just first want to clarify
that I was opposed to the cecu in back
in May when they lifted the indoor Mass
requirement I thought that the honor
code was never going to work that when
vaccinated and vaccinated people are
mixing unless there is proof of
vaccination everybody should still be
wearing masks and so I actually support
what the CDC is now doing which is going
back to this indoor mask requirement
because frankly we know that we can't
trust the unvaccinated them they have
been walking around without masks and in
fact that's what led to the surge that
we're seeing the vaccine is the ticket
back to pre-pandemic life and the window
to do that is really narrowing I mean
you were mentioning Chris about how all
these states are reopening they're
reopening at a hundred percent and we
have a very narrow window to tie
reopening policy to vaccination status
because otherwise if everything is
reopened then what's the carrot going to
be how are we going to incentivize
people to actually get the vaccine so
that's why I think the CDC and the broad
Administration needs to come out a lot
Bolder and say if you're vaccinated you
can do all these things hear all these
freedoms that you have because otherwise
people are going to go out and enjoy
these freedoms anyway
oh
if you need a moment to grab a bucket
and puke
maybe I could pause for just a second
because she's disgusting absolutely
disgusting there is so much it's not
just that it's dishonesty in there and
and this deep like desire to control
people but the way she says it I don't
understand why people have Choice that's
what she said I don't understand why
people have the choice
I understand because in America you got
Choice lady okay that's number one then
at the end what's the carrot if you open
up everything she's telling you we are
the government and she's she's a
government agent she's not a she's not a
journalist even though they put her on
the cloud Network CNN what is the carrot
if we let them do things mean meaning if
we just give them Freedom which they
think they give us right which they
don't give us but they think they give
it to us and actually the more that we
let them believe that the more that
they'll keep taking uh then then why why
would they do what we want if they've
already got the carrot right because
rabbits like carrots and rabbits usually
uh when they're domesticated live in
little cages and that's what they love
for us so this woman is an extraordinary
liar what she's realizing right now and
what CNN and this is what I taught what
I'm saying about the The Narrative shift
they're all realizing that everyone
really hates the Democrats right now and
you really should you really should I
mean that these people have destroyed
lives they have they have broken our
education system they have caused
depression and drug use to Skyrocket
they have destroyed our cities
um the the damage that has been done
because of democrat policies all of
these people cheered on by the media who
are just Democrats on television
um the damage that has been done will be
two generations easily the I knew it you
go back to the videos that I was doing
two weeks after covet I did the two-week
thing we all did the two-week thing and
then I started saying you know the old
world ain't coming back it's pretty
obvious it's pretty obvious and those
people have killed the old world and
they are trying to condition us to a new
world that is going to be much worse
okay much worse so now here's another
Democrat this is representative Hakeem
Jeffries from New York and you're not
going to believe who's who who is he
crediting you're not going to believe it
because the states are going to start
opening up now kind of doing what
Florida's been doing all along doing
what Texas has kind of been doing and
Tennessee's been doing and all those
scary Red states have been doing who's
he crediting now that the blue states
are going to open up because they want
to win in the midterms yeah he's
crediting Brandon take a look and the
Omicron variant is in retreat
and that's not by accident that's
because under President Biden's
leadership a public health
infrastructure was put into place
beginning with the American Rescue plan
without a single Republican vote
to ensure that we can do everything
possible to crush the virus and that is
what has been happening
I'm gonna have to start drinking in the
middle of the day
I really am I don't like day drinking I
know a lot of people like to Day drink
even on the weekends never been a fan
okay I like drinking when it's dark out
but the extraordinary level of Lies it's
thanks to to Joe Biden that Omicron is
in retreat no it isn't it's because the
vaccines did not work the way that Joe
Biden and lyanna Wen and fauci and
wolensky and all of you collection of
elitist Liars pushed on us it didn't
work that way and guess what happened
over Christmas and into the New Year
everyone basically got Omicron or got
some variant of kovid including yours
truly and I did have leg pains for three
days and then I took the monoclonal
treatment which was easily accessible
here in Florida which now the federal
government has stopped I took Ivermectin
which isn't just a horse paste and yes I
was okay in three days and some people
were a little more sick David was a
little more sick my brother got it at
the exact same time as me he wasn't
really sick I wasn't really sick I'm not
vaccinated he is every everyone made
choices for themselves it has nothing
absolutely nothing to do with the
policies of these people and let's not
forget I wish we would have grabbed the
clip uh let's not forget what Joe Biden
said uh what was it right around
Thanksgiving about how the winter is
going to be a winter of death for the
unvaccinated huh didn't really come to
pass did it could it just be that you're
a fear-mongering lunatic who just reads
off the teleprompter or whatever they
put in front of you well you know what's
happening
you know what's happening at this very
minute we've been covering it here
you're probably not seeing it on
mainstream media there actually is a
shift there is a shift because good
decent people from the bottom up are
starting to fight back and it's
happening in all places in the world
it's happening in Canada and we know all
about the the trucker Convoy I'm gonna
do a little bit more on that uh in just
a few minutes but now the premiere of
Alberta Jason Kinney is dropping
restrictions because people peacefully
protested because they exercise their
rights that they have in a western free
democracy and they stood up to the
fraudulent the fraudulent chronic liar
that is just in Trudeau take a look the
threat of covid-19 to Public Health is
no no longer outweighs the hugely
damaging impact of Health restrictions
on our society on people's Mental Health
on their emotional well-being on uh our
broader social health
so now is the time to begin learning to
live with kovic
these restrictions have led to terrible
division even amongst families and
friends and inflamed sometimes tensions
in our communities and neighborhoods
covid and the restrictions associated
with it have robbed thousands of young
children with the simple joys of just
being a kid
guys guys do you think it's a
coincidence that he's saying this now or
do you think it might have something to
do with groups of individual people
fighting back saying no you don't own us
we are going to take our lives in our
own hands we are going to join together
and fight for what's right which is what
they're doing and they're doing it
freaking peacefully and they're doing it
all over the nation not just in Alberta
not just in Ottawa uh we've got some
some video of the Convoy right here
let's take a look at that I mean it's
just look at that that is absolutely
extraordinary what they're doing those
are thousands of good people who are not
out there because they hate trans people
or have a new rational fear I should say
they have an irrational fear of trans
people and that's why they're out there
in the Convoy that's literally what
Trudeau said and tweeted they have an
illegitimate fear of Muslims and that's
why they're out there they're white
supremacists God these people the gall
like what I don't know what could have
happened to the human soul that could
lead them to that place but it's not
just Justin Trudeau who's soulless it
really is not you all know my favorite
lady over in DC Jen soccer uh she's
lying about what's happening up in
Canada take a look
the truckers Canada last night shut down
the Ambassador Bridge which carries
about a quarter of U.S Canada trading
Goods so what's the administration's
response uh to this action and what
steps are being taken to ensure the free
flow of goods and also any preventative
steps being taken to address a possible
blockade on the Michigan side of that
bridge well let me first start by saying
I know there's been some suggestion not
by reporters necessarily at all but that
this congestion is related to the
vaccine requirements it's not I mean I
I'm saying I'm going to get to the
protests but the protests uh going on
across Canada which have spread to a
bridge or leading to sporadic congestion
and blockages
all right first off I want to give her
credit because she's actually dressed
like a witch and it's like a little on
the nose so good for you saki
um now interestingly as per what she
said there about the truckers and what's
happening there's this guy up in Canada
who actually
completely disagrees with her I think
one of the things we all understand is
just how frustrated everyone is
um we're all frustrated we're all sick
and tired of restrictions of of mandates
of having to to make sacrifices of not
being able to do the things we love I
can understand frustrations with
mandates but mandates are the way to
avoid further restrictions or having to
be restricted as people get vaccinated
as Canadians have gotten vaccinated
we've been able to get through things
and this team is going to stay focused
on doing exactly that we're all so
frustrated nobody know how this thing
happened we don't know we mandates are
the way to Freedom well I don't know who
did this who's in charge around here I
just have nice hair and I wear my my
socks and people think that I'm a really
nice guy even though I'm an evil [ __ ]
okay so I don't know how any of this
happened
here's Trudeau saying the complete
opposite individuals
are trying to blockade
our economy
our democracy
and our fellow citizens daily lives
it has to stop
freaking individuals is there anything
worse than individuals
you know peacefully doing stuff and
saying that we're not going to bow to
the king is there anything worse
cleaning up garbage shoveling snow
helping old people across the street is
there anything worse than individuals
well it's not just Justin Trudeau I I
like that Justin Trudeau impression what
do you think it's pretty good hey
anyways somebody told me that something
was happening right you know I talk like
this so it seems like I'm not evil or
that I don't have bad intentions but I'm
really a frighteningly horrible person
um it's not just Justin Trudeau though
who is lying flat out lying about the
intentions and the motives and the
actual reality on the ground that the
truckers are doing uh it's all of our
mainstream media we've got quite a
compilation for you sedition
Insurrection a threat to democracy this
city is under siege they are now calling
it an occupation an alarming situation
there in Ottawa the police chief is
calling it a Nationwide Insurrection
driven by Madness this is kind of our
Insurrection by air horn momentous I
think it's part of the globalization of
trumpism Canadians know where I stand
there hasn't been as much violence as
some had perhaps projected but that does
not necessarily mean that it has been
peaceful reports of severe vandalism and
criminal Behavior streets are clogged
the honking is incessant and deafening
this pandemic has sucked for all
Canadians residents that I have spoken
to who say they feel terrorized
intimidated residents say they feel like
hostages residents in that area say that
they are being held hostage that this
Freedom has essentially this Freedom
Convoy as they call it has essentially
imposed a lockdown on them some
protesters harassed a soup kitchen these
anti-vaxxers actually took food from the
mouths of the homeless hungry yeah
because they were they're so put upon
there have not been any violent
outbursts however horns have been
honking for 12 to 21 hours a night
small Fringe minority
of people who are on their way to Ottawa
or who are holding unacceptable views
that they're expressing many of them are
holding Confederate flags I've heard
there's Q Anon supporters in the crowd
we've seen swastikas we've seen the
Confederate flag we've seen flags with
Justin Trudeau our prime minister in a
news lots of Donald Trump flags as well
people chanting let's go Brandon it is
actually one of the rare times in
history you're going to see swastikas
and yellow stars at the same protest
foreign
what is a human
what is a human being like what are
those people doing I can accept that a
certain amount of them are brainwashed
and I can accept that a certain amount
of them just want a gig that it's nice
to be on TV
they put makeup on you you know it's
nice they do your hair they might give
you clothes I do my own hair they do
whack me with powder I pick out my own
clothes
um but these people have sold their
souls I don't know what how else can you
describe human beings
who lie as their main ethos the main
driver of what they do is to lie about
people
I I don't know how else you can describe
it they want there to be violence you
could that one woman there hasn't been a
violence really and you know there's
swastikas and there's we don't see any
images of any of this they showed one
Confederate flag because Trump signs
everywhere haven't seen those but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's something
bad these people are evil and just
juxtapose that with how they treated the
actually violent riots that we had all
over the United States of America for
the last two years except you know it
was odd I I have to look into this why
did all of those race riots stop the
second that Joe Biden became president
did we solve racism did we solve the
policing thing and all the systemic
stuff and all that stuff did we solve
all that or could it be that that's
actually the Democrats and the media
working together to destroy Trump and
then they you know they stop it when
they need it to be stopped and you know
then their guy was in power crazy right
um these are bad people they did not
cover as a matter of fact they would
either ignore the violence when they
were attacking the federal courthouse in
Portland and when they were burning down
buildings or they would
obfuscate it in such a way that you
wouldn't understand who was doing the
violence so cities would be burning
cities in Wisconsin Cities Minneapolis
like you've all seen the stuff I mean
you know right now go to New York City
watch watch people just walk in and
steal a whole bunch of stuff out of CBS
you can do whatever you want in these
cities the drugs that are everywhere
though but those are peaceful things
where I used to live in Los Angeles when
they took all of Ventura Boulevard and
they had to blockade all of the
restaurants and all of the shops there
the mom and pop shops and they had to
put BLM on them and they were doing it
because they loved BLM so much or was
that it was their hostage situation
we're we we know you guys are the
tolerant ones and that's why we're
boarding up our windows and saying that
we love you because you guys are
tolerant you guys are the good guys
everything is backwards people it is
your job as a as a thinking free person
to fight for what's right right now
because they're coming and they're doing
it you have to admire it this is the
Matrix this is the machine in The Matrix
they're somehow always one step ahead of
us I don't know how they do it I really
don't out and I kind of admire it I'd
like to figure it out but you cannot
forget who got us here and how they got
us here okay you cannot forget and you
must remember when you vote and I can
only imagine the shenanigans they're
going to come up with since and how
they'll try to link the truckers further
with the the January 6th Insurrection
and God knows what they will do God
knows what they will do until this
election like it's really really crazy
but stop letting these people abuse your
children because that's what they're
doing that's what they're doing uh Stacy
Abrams who who believes in election
fraud when when she loses and she's
allowed to talk about it and be treated
as a hero again I have no idea why
anyone knows who she is other than she
contested uh the election in Georgia
right nobody knows who she is or why
she's there you know nobody knows but
they she's she's a child abuser what
else are you other than that when you
gleefully can we get the image one more
time you griefly look at her look at her
there's only one person in that room who
may baby maybe is is in risk of covid
and it's her and she's the one not
wearing the mask but why did she do well
because they had to hear me
I don't like these people very much
that's the show oh no that's not the
show for today we gotta if you I hope
you enjoy the show today I enjoyed doing
the show today but we got a real outro
for you uh that daily wire put together
but before I get to that a couple
comments from reubenreport.locals.com
and appreciate you all you guys who are
in the comment section as we're doing
the show live Hawk says science changes
ah so it's not settled
great Point Hawk great point we're
always told science is settled until
they unsettle it and now it's settled
with their new settling or something
like that awful Leanne when you were a
terrible terrible human uh Russell says
they always bring the narrative back to
vaccines and completely leave out the
fact that you can still transmit covid
with it you can get coveted with the
vaccine you can transmit covid with the
vaccine I was booted from Twitter for
saying that back in July Candace says
Omicron will go away and we will be back
to the common cold just in time for
midterms yes that's what this is all
about that's what this is all about they
are looking at internal polling
and they are saying holy [ __ ] we
overstepped maybe abusing people's
children for two years was a bit much
maybe destroying everyone's lives with
lives was a bit much
maybe look at the rate of drug use and
depression and boy maybe it had
something to do with us
um we better do something about that but
now the thing that you need to know is
that the machine will now do something
with that the media the Democrats the
entire machine is somehow over the next
six months going to make it seem like
the Republicans were the ones locking
people down and it was the good
Democrats like Stacy Abrams who are
trying to save us
from the evil Republicans that's what's
on the way know it just know that and
don't forget that and then I think you
can you can think clearly about the
issues going forward uh so to end
Today's Show and I hope you enjoyed
another one of these narrative shows I
dig this I think we're gonna we're gonna
keep doing more of these uh the daily
wire put together a spectacular
spectacular destruction of the
mainstream media and why these clowns
and that's what they are why these
clowns in suits should not be trusted
I'll see you tomorrow this brand new
research by Gallup says American Trust
in the mass media is at its lowest point
since 2016 and near a record low overall
Jeff Zucker has announced his immediate
resignation as the president of CNN this
comes amid an investigation into what
Jeff Zucker calls a consensual
relationship what happened and where CNN
goes from here you were caught
masturbating on camera you since then
have been on leave from CNN do I have
all that right um You got it all right
sad to say the biggest media story this
weekend it's the firing of Chris Cuomo
from this Network CNN late Wednesday a
lawyer contacted CNN with a sexual
misconduct complaint about Cuomo joining
me now the man who accused Don Lemon of
sexual assault his accuser claims lemon
started rubbing himself but the even
bigger point I think is about what the
Press is is it produced by reporters or
by repeaters repeaters are the talk
radio shouters they're on TV and radio
telling the same story every day
president Trump president Trump
president Trump Trump trump Trump trump
Trump trump Trump trump Trump trump
Trump trump Donald Trump Donald Trump
calling the same story every day
repeaters are Twitter trolls who
anonymously amplify propaganda and try
to wear the rest of us down with their
repetition January 6th January 6th
January 6 January 6th January 6th to
January 6th January 6th January 6th
repetition January 6 Insurrection the
Insurrection the Insurrection
Insurrection the Insurrection the
Insurrection Insurrection Insurrection
repetition repetition repetition so much
of what they are repeating is from
reporters from the people pay to figure
out what is true we're widely holds
conspiracy theory that the coronavirus
was created in the Chinese laboratory Dr
fauci thank you uh for keeping it
straight Thank You For Fighting the good
fight we know the science we know that
masks work what we have now is a
pandemic of the unvaccinated this is
really now a pandemic of the
unvaccinated this is now a pandemic of
the unvaccinated this is now a pandemic
of the unvaccinated this is now a
pandemic much of the dossier has been
corroborated what does Putin have on
Trump has Trump been compromised but it
does look like that young man to me is
taunting the Native American Vietnam vet
and he's in his face there is no
evidence of any wrongdoing by either
hunter or Joe Biden there's no evidence
of wrongdoing by either Joe or Hunter
Biden what you're seeing behind me is
one of multiple locations that have been
burning in Kenosha this isn't about
ideology the biggest Terror threat in
this country comes from radicals on the
far right primarily white men as a white
woman aware of my own privilege in this
country I am so angry and I can't even
begin
now too many see the protests as the
problem no the problem is what forced
your fellow citizens to take to the
streets a few moments later
[Music]
fake news we are real news and now the
two faces of Hillary Clinton are coming
out the fact through Wikileaks that she
says one thing uh
oh oh no all right let's see if we can
get Congressman Collins back obviously
we just lost the satellite feed that
sucks routinely at these rallies we were
hearing a chance of CNN sucks
this is CNN the most trusted name
CNN sucks man